welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and today i'm joined
by cat clancy and this is another
episode of the 15 minutes with a mentor
series
which we're releasing in line with the
launch of the recruitment mentors
community
and in this series very simply we're
speaking to some of the mentors
from inside the community and we're
asking them seven questions
in 15 minutes so before i ask you the
first question cat if you could
introduce yourself for those that may
not know
who you are and then we'll get into it
okay
hello i'm kat um i have been in
recruitment for 13 years
um i started at a boutique legal
recruitment agency
totally by accident as i think most of
us do
met but absolutely loved it i started in
the accounts team
then moved to recruitment administrator
and worked my way up to
company director in six years um
after that i was there for about two or
three years as director
moved to another boutique legal agency
set up a new team new division temp
division
and then decided to do it on my own
um so that's where finally partners was
born
we are just over a year old um
great year to start a business obviously
um but
it's definitely it's been challenging
but so rewarding
so that brings us up to amazing awesome
so first question for you is and it'll
be interesting to hear this with what
you just shared with us so
what has been your biggest challenge in
2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
so many challenges
um and i narrowed it down to sort of two
big ones but i think
this is the one that hopefully will kind
of
resonate with a few people as well and
be quite useful
um for me was on boarding
team members training and managing
remotely
and i think especially with my style
before was
much more immersive so it was
kind of on the desk listening to
conversations
at the end of phone calls saying oh you
should say this or maybe try this next
time well this was great
and very much kind of uh was all about
being
together on a desk and obviously
having someone start in the middle of a
pandemic where everyone's in lockdown
that couldn't happen so
i found that really challenging um to
sort of completely rewire almost like 12
years of doing something
the same way and and actually
do it in this new challenging
environment
um so something i had to do which
giving my my age away slightly is had to
embrace
new technology um so
using even just conference calls to
listen to phone calls
and having the zoom meetings and things
like that
um being much better with things like
trello and other things like that which
i had never
used before six months ago um
and then i think the other part of that
was for me
i'd always been much more about talking
things through
but putting things down on paper
creating manuals creating guides
which well hopefully sort of going
forward as we've got a new person
starting in a couple of weeks
will make that process a lot easier
in the future nice nice thank you for
sharing that
um so what working from home tip
could you share with other recruiters
listening to this that
has had a sort of massive impact on your
own productivity
so for me it's structuring the day
and when you go to work you know you
have to start time
yeah you should have your 12 twos when
you can take lunch and you know
that you leave at a certain time when
you're at home things
do blur um and i think
sometimes it's a bit harder to get going
in the morning and
sometimes you can work through and
realize you've not i think there was a
week i didn't leave
the house i was like that's not good for
anyone um so just kind of working out a
structure
that works for you and and then for me
the first thing i do in the morning i
set one task that i know i want done by
10 o'clock
and like a simpler task i suppose but
then that really sets me up for the rest
of the day working at home
nice so what has been the most effective
way for you to win business in the last
12 months
um so this actually kind of tied into my
other binge
because i had planned for a one-year
birthday
with the this in-person event and
get all of my clients kind of back on
board after restrictions
that couldn't happen so it has
definitely been
uh instead of having to think a bit more
creatively
but the thing that has worked is
actually been
our sort of branding and our message
and which for us is very much diversity
sort of so it's making sure we're
constantly
sort of being the leaders in the legal
recruitment industry about what we're
doing about it
and and using things like mailchimp and
canva and just creating like really
slick looking
materials to send out and people love
the message
so that's where everyone is amazing
that's awesome and great that you're um
doing that so the next thing that i want
to know
is what habit or hobby did you start in
2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
i don't know if this counts but it's
is dog ownership does that count as a
whole yeah
we can count that okay thanks
so uh yes i've wanted a puppy
for about 10 years now um and
finally it just kind of made sense being
at home
being able to train it give it a good
life so uh
it comes with that is walking which i
never did before
and i now love going for walks so
um awesome
so i want to know from you what do you
think
is better the first coffee in the
morning
or the first pint post work on a friday
friday yes
and you know and i think why so we um
with my team my last company would
always do
it's the same as you do actually the the
end of the week wins
and i think that's such a nice time for
me is like actually do you know what
something will have gone well this week
and i think just in our nature as
recruiters we like
you know to we're slightly competitive
we like to win um
and so i think i kind of find on a
friday is that like oh we've made it
through the week
this has gone well let's celebrate yeah
i love that
so this is a slightly different one
but i just want to sort of hear how
you'd approach this scenario so the
scenario is
a particular business that has been on
your target client list for
over a year a long time and during that
time
there's been a number of touch points
they may have engaged with some of your
content that you've been sort of
um sharing around diversity inclusion or
you may have sent a couple of emails and
sent some of your
emails through mailchimp or whatever
right um but through your candidate
network
you're able to get one of the hiring
manager's contact details at this
company
so you call that person they pick up
they say hello who is this and
i want to hear how you would approach
that or sort of what you'd sort of
attempt to say and trying to get across
in that first interaction
okay so um
this is something i haven't done in a
while um
so very lucky i suppose just with
uh having worked in the same industry
for such a long time
uh people stay in the legal industry as
well so
the sort of network is there um
but i would say it's adding value
and don't i think they don't really care
about you
and who you are it's what can you add
value to them and
or there is another route which is
people like to help people so if you've
got this line manager
who um well maybe i'll give you an
example of something we're about to do
starting a role remotely so it could be
more along the lines of oh great um
have you got some tips i've seen you had
two team members start we're doing this
series to help candidates because
obviously really tough at the moment
and we'd really love your expertise to
help
put this together for them nice yeah
yeah and then it just the conversation
just goes from there they see you
as you want to be seen which is uh
knowledgeable
market leader and actually helpful and
then that will really help strengthen
the relationship
yeah i really like that as well bringing
into sort of some sort of context or
to showcase that you actually looked
before you called and things like that
right so that's
um really good and that's been a really
common theme which i think is just
fascinating is this whole idea of giving
more than you take
which is just super counterintuitive of
what you used to get
sort of told at the beginning of your
career right you cat comes off a
business development call and the first
question you get asked is
what did you get out of that call right
and i think this sort of thing that
we're learning here is
what would happen or what would happen
to people's careers or
how would they approach recruitment
differently if that question instead was
what value did you offer on that call
right um
so i love that so final question i want
you to sort of imagine i'm a
i'm a recruiter i've set my goals for
2021 i am
motivated to have a better year than
2020
and i want sort of your advice to me on
how can i give myself and the people
listening to this
have the best possible chance of
achieving the goals that we've
set this year what would you say to
those people and me
okay so i think the most important thing
to start with is think of why
what's your why why have you set this
goal um
and make sure there's value in it for
you to achieving it
so if you've got little interest in the
outcome or they're irrelevant
then the chances of you putting the work
in to make it happen are pretty slim
and that can be something sort of
outside of work
it doesn't have to be kind of work
related just to have that reason why
you've got that as your goal and second
tip would be to
break the main goal down into smaller
goals so they're more manageable
and and set those time frames so whether
it's kind of
weekly or monthly whatever works for you
um
my third would be to start either the
day or the week
with the quickest or easiest win
um then i would say
hold yourself accountable um
and although some life coaches and
things like that will say
uh put your money behind it um of which
story of my pt was told to buy an audi
r8 which he could not afford because
that would make him work harder
i definitely do not recommend that um
what i think does work well is creating
social pressure
so uh yeah i mean nobody likes to look
you know stupid in front of other people
um
so sometimes just by like telling people
that's what your goal is
or and you know posting it on social
media or something
that actually holds you accountable so
that you can achieve yeah that's a great
tip
i have yeah i do that with one of my
friends we sort of catch up every
two weeks and sort of share what you
want to achieve and yeah you're gonna
if i said yeah i'm this is sort of what
i want to do and then you go to that
call
and that you get asked did you do and
you say no then you feel
like you said you feel silly you feel
awkward it's like oh [ __ ] why didn't i
do that
yes and maybe that hour just before the
phone call you're like oh my god what
can i do
exactly so i love that yeah amazing yeah
and then
final tip is reward yourself um
and i think for me i've got a goal this
week
and if i do it i get a nando's on friday
night so
you know i'm gonna make sure i do it
yeah i love that
cat that was 15 minutes with a mentor
thank you
thank you